disconnected oh no my McCarthy Stone
yeah time just found your favorite
emotes
got some angry gooses
all right let me try and win a game and
recover my rating a little bit
we have a jobava London
B5
I don't think this changes my strategy
much
B4 usually I can play Knight A4
as a similar opening my first game my
opponent just plundered The Rook like
playing my G4 and aloud Bishop h8
well we see a similar blender
probably not
so I have F3
actually f3h5
is interesting
because if Knight takes H5 I can dig
with Rook
ponding H5 I did not calculate
Bishop D3
Queen A5 might be coming
yeah maybe I should have castled first
play A3 first
usually with A3 included it makes less
sense to Castle
because B4 can come what is H6
but I think I can just play this anyway
because B4 I have Knight A2
wow
I'm already smelling some goodness
start with King B1 so I'm threatening
maybe this but maybe not
yeah definitely not
I'm 94.
that E4 is a cool move
it's a party in the center
so the point is black can't take because
I win the queen and if Queen takes Queen
I have my C5 check in between move
and it's a really nice just positional
position
I guess all positions are positional by
Nature
uh A4
wanna eventually get this Rook involved
the king is almost an amazing that
black is actually really tied down too
wow there's a funny line
does it work
I can't resist I mean I'm so tilted now
I can't resist
so there's a line
how would it even work though A5
so I'm taking away these squares from
the King I'm set to play like a five or
even B4 A5 checkmates
I guess idea like black can move the
bishop anywhere to attack my Bishop
that's a move
can I play B4
I can't resist I'm going like all out
I might be losing some pawns but
it's worth
trying to get the funny lines
because look at the minor pieces like
they're all
swarming around the king
like hungry sharks
or hungry snakes
or a singular hungry like Boa
Constructor
grip is is tightening a little bit
yeah so the idea was to take and then
play Bishop A7
taking away the B6 Square from the King
I'm trying to bring the king closer to
me
like uh
a magnet
I have to use my magnetic
powers
check
come closer
take my snack
in B2
oh it's such a funny line
look at this move King B2
oh no my Bishop
I think yeah that's the point of no
return for back
Rook A1 is Unstoppable
it is delayable
black has one Spike Chuck
Rook A7 Rook A1
King B4
and then C3 checkmates
don't flag I want I want the pawn
Checkmate ah okay
let me just show it
oh what a funny game
so it takes here here this could have
been the final position
C3 completing my London opening a very
delayed completion of the pawn triangle
that was a fun game
I mean I took some
maybe over the top risks that I would
not have taken otherwise
uh like this bishop B8 move but maybe
it's the best move like the king gets
very stuck
hey Bishop B it's the best move Bishop
B8 A5 hey I played like stockfish
I played exactly like stockfish
but I was using my own brain